you know it's funny cuz I just mentioned
since these early days it's starting it
live I still remember I worked at CERN
out live the day that you arrived you
were wearing I remembered you I visually
is really remember you walking through
the door and saying hi I'm Mike Meyers
and shaking my hand and you were wearing
a leather jacket and I remember thinking
this guy's going places well I'm glad
you thought that yeah yeah I thought I
was gonna get fired every week so that's
true oh yeah yeah but you were extremely
nice to me and I was always appreciated
that and the first day made me feel very
comfortable and at home and then you put
this note in my my desk when did I leave
you this number by the way this is true
people gonna think this is absolutely I
actually wrote this note and and I left
this for you yeah which I thought was
very very nice but I wasn't sure what
was going at first and I was a little
afraid because I was just you know just
got off the boat from Toronto I didn't
know what's going on but you shouldn'ta
taken a boat anyway go ahead now you
tell me all the way around the whole
canal but let's show people this note
yes I don't know why I did this
it says Mike I'm going to destroy you
I'm not sure how I'm not sure when but I
will destroy and the best part is that
no one will believe I had anything to do
with it in my house for six years on the
bulletin board yeah I actually
remembered at the time thinking it's
really funny for someone to write a note
like that and say and no one will ever
know it was me signed I own it did that
but that didn't freak you out at the
time no no no but whenever you you know
I I put you in sketches and stuff so is
that not to be destroyed by that's right
what actually worked because whenever
you would write a sketch I remembered
you would always try and figure out a
way you know to work Coenen into yeah
you know I've just originally was it was
Wayne and Conan I think Wayne and Garth
and I think it should be Dana
yeah but there and we fought bitterly
about that I remember it was a bitter
bitter column yes yeah but I feel better
now yeah you did put me in you put me in
handsome man yes I believe we have a
clip of that yeah
this is me a long time ago let's take a
look at this I believe this gentleman
has something to say well I just
completed your course I never dreamed
that could be this handsome
thanks Lang you're handsome
you know what tells me about that they
showed that to me this morning and I was
like my head is forty pounds heavier
today but it wasn't what that one that's
1990 or 1989 I think something like that
well you had a pretty big noggin then oh
yeah always nice now we we actually
turnabout is fair play we actually have
a clip of some of your early work when
you were a quite a young lad oh right
let's let's let's roll this please I
think this is only fair let's take a
look
[Music]
it's Wrigley's yeah well you graduated
to the big stick the name's Ned Joey
yeah a real straight
[Music]
you rascal hello first of all how old
how old are you in that commercial I'm
about eight no no I think about eleven
I'm not sure actually but the horrible
thing is is try like you know being in a
public school in the suburbs of Toronto
and just have the whole school turn you
and go hey you graduate to the big stick
[Laughter]
but slightly disturbing slightly
slightly homoerotic I thought that looks
a little dicey there yeah yeah and
they're probably still parts of Canada
where no matter what else you achieve
and you've achieved a lot they're still
gonna hold you accountable for that
commercial yeah there's some legislation
in Canada pending have to go to jail or
something right right now speaking of
things that haunt you Austin Powers big
success unfortunately such a big success
that it inspires porno movies yeah and
yeah what happens is it's like they have
a movie and then you know if it does
okay they make a porno version of it
yeah yeah when you're sitting there
writing Austin Powers it's like oh yeah
yeah James Bond in the sixties and stuff
like that I I never think to cut cut to
later that there's a this no versions
didn't prowler which actually is a like
I can't show you the back of the box I
will enjoy that yes
you know tune this tune to Cinemax right
now we're showing in the back of the box
but Austin prowler have you have you
checked this movie out and I saw it
actually I didn't I didn't pay to go see
it it was sent to me by a friend but
it's a what's so interesting is that
it's like you know lines from the movie
so there's like you know a guy playing
Austin Powers and it's like yeah baby
and then it's like you know we got to
save the world but first and then it's
just that kind of slap ass porn sex dr.
Evil's like you know I've got myself a
new laser but first and then instead of
him being cryogenically frozen and
coming out of like a chamber right he
comes out of a fridge that's been
spray-painted red one of those fridges
that you normally take the doors off but
so you know it's a little bit of smoke
and he comes out and and you should show
a clip for god sakes yeah we weren't
gonna show a clip and then Mike showed
up and said you must show a clip you
throw it what say enjoy this now this
clip from Austin because there's a
complicated plot it's a complicated plug
let's just roll this clip of Austin
Prowler we've got to get his mojo
anybody have any ideas I think I can
help I know CPR
that was originally in Austin Powers
that's it so weird but evidently the
sensor said no yeah there's a there's a
Wayne's World
porno as well it's called Zane's world
and so they so lame I know and they sit
there and they go Zane's world aids
world okay we're going to do a show but
first it's all just sex
that's so romantic it is it actually
it's it's a little disgusting because
genitals aren't good looking and it's
just a lot of like I don't know where
you've been but no it's funky I mean I'd
say yeah no kidding hardcore yeah
offering so I don't endorse children to
go out and buy that please yeah yeah the
funny the funny thing is that we find
out that this thing existed and so we
actually have a whole research
department we said someone you know go
out and buy Austin Prowler so that we
can show it and they spent like a whole
day looking and they couldn't find it
anywhere and then someone who works on
staff was like oh I got it
push eject on their VCR